le liban est plongé dans le noir depuis
au-moins midi les habitants sont privés
d'électricité
un problème de taille pour ce citoyen
qui habite au 11e étage de son immeuble
lorsque l'ascenseur est hors d'usagé
raconte il ne peut se rendre jusqu'à son
appartement et doit souvent se résoud à
dormir dans son auto à l'origine de
cette coupure une importante pénurie de
mazout qui empêche les deux plus grande
centrale électrique de fonctionner le
liban est un pays en faillite et donc il
n'a pas de devises pour se procurer l'or
noir qu'il nécessite pour faire marcher
ses centrales
depuis des mois le pays connaît des
rationnements d'électricité draconien
mais cette fois-ci tout le monde est
touché même les commerçants
la coupure est mauvais sur tous les
fronts 10 propriétaire d'un magasin elle
nous empêche d'obtenir ou d'utiliser les
outils dont nous avons besoin pour
travailler c'est que les services privés
qui fournissent normalement en
électricité à leurs abonnés en cas de
panne sont eux aussi à court le
gouvernement libanais formé il ya
quelques semaines a indiqué que
l'électricité ne serait pas de retour
avant lundi au plus tôt pour la suite
des choses il s'est tourné vers les pays
voisins pour tenter de s'approvisionner
en pétrole l'irak a déjà promis d'en
distribuer en échange de services
médicaux
les ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'iran promet de continuer à en livrer
aussi
déjà le mouvement chiite hezbollah
facilite le transport d'importantes
quantités de pétrole iranien au liban
une participation critiqué par des
observateurs internationaux qui accuse
le groupe armé de profiter de la crise
pour créer un état dans l'état ici
alexandre et belle-ile radio canada
montréal